اتصل علي رئيس ديوان الملكي رياض ابو كركي
وهذا يعني بيني وبين والده وصداقه وفي
معرفه عائليه فقال لجلالته بده اياك تتصل
بالاخوان فقلت لهم انتم جايين علي انا
اتصل بالاخوان ما انا امبارح متهوش انا
والاخوان
فروحوا شوفوا واحد يعني انسب يعني الاخوان
مش هياخذوا كلامي انا فقال لمين قلت
رجاء المعشر همم مسيحي اردني وشخصيه
سياسيه طاهر المصري يعني شخص يكون حيادي
اما انا اعتبر طرف يعني ربما هذا
فقال لي طيب خليني اشوف
بعد ساعات اتصل قال لي وجدنا اثنين مشهور
في بيني وبين الاخوان اتصال ما في الا
صديقي الدكتور رحيل كان لانه استاذ معنا
في الجامعه فاتت عليكم قلت له في معي
رساله شفويه ملكيه للاخوان اذا بحبوا
يسمعوها الدكتور
كلم الاخوان وفعلا قالوا اليوم الفلاني
رحت انا التقينا في جريده السبيل وكان
عاطف الجولاني رئيس تحرير وكان حمزه منصور
العربيه موجود
الملك يريد منكم ان تشاركه في الانتخابات
يعني مشتركه
ويعتقد ان وجودكم في البرلمان بشكل اضافه
اي دوله انتخابات
ما سمعت جواب جماعه
واحد يكون بدناش الصوت بدنا قائمه على
مستوى الاردن واحد بيكون بدنا الغاء
المعاهده واحد
فانا يعني هذا مش غريب علي اني اعرفه لانه
الاخوان هذا موضوعهم مفروض انه يقولوا
ندرس الامر ونرد لك خبر الجماعه مش كل
واحد يشتهي من عنده
قلت لهم انا بدي ارجع بجواب اعطوني جواب
انا سمعت سبع اجوبه فاي اجوبه
قلت لهم على كل الملك انه انتم بدكم صوتين
انا اقتراح
قالوا بتمون
فرجعتم بلغت رئيس الديوان على التليفون
قلت له الجماعه بدون صوتين